ما هي أفكارك
،
من الأسهل أن تكون والدًا هذا
الصباح ، من الأسهل أن تكون أبًا
، من الأسهل أن تخبر
شخصية أطفالك بالأمور المهمة ، قول
الحقيقة
يهم أن تكون شخصًا
جيدًا هو أمر أسهل لكثير  من
الناس
إذا كنت مسلمًا في هذا البلد ،
فلا داعي للقلق إذا كان الرئيس
لا يريدك هنا
إذا كنت مهاجرًا ، فلا
داعي للقلق إذا كان الرئيس سيكون
سعيدًا
بخطف الأطفال.  بعيدًا أو أرسل الحالمين
مرة أخرى دون سبب ،
فهذا تبرر لكثير من الأشخاص
الذين عانوا حقًا ،
أعلم أنني لا أستطيع التنفس ، كما تعلمون ،
لم يكن جورج
فلويد فقط ، فقد شعر الكثير من الناس
أنهم لا يستطيعون التنفس
كل يوم تستيقظ
وتتلقى هذه التغريدات
ولا تعرفها وأنت ذاهب إلى المتجر والأشخاص
الذين
يخشون إظهار عنصريتهم يزدادون
شرا وأشرار لك وأنت
قلق على
أطفالك وأنت قلق  عن أختك
وهل يمكنها الذهاب إلى وول مارت
والعودة إلى سيارتها دون أن
يقول لها أحدهم شيئًا
، وقد قضيت الكثير من
طاقة حياتك في
محاولة تجميعها معًا وهذا
أمر مهم
بالنسبة لنا فقط  قادر على الحصول على بعض
السلام ولديك فرصة لإعادة التعيين
، وشخصية البلد
مهمة وكونك رجلًا صالحًا أمر مهم
كما تعلم ، أريد فقط لأولادي أن
ينظروا إلى هذه النظرة ،
تعلمون أنه سهل  للقيام بذلك بالطريقة الرخيصة
و و و و والابتعاد عن الأشياء ، لكن
الأمر يعود من
حوله ويعود مرة أخرى وهو يوم
جيد لهذا البلد ، أنا آسف
للأشخاص الذين
فقدوني بالنسبة لهم ، إنه ليس جيدًا  يوم ولكن بالنسبة
لكثير من الناس هو يوم جيد